traveling to Amsterdam and the
Netherlands was great for several
reasons not only did I get to meet some
great friends and colleagues for the
first time in person and even hang out
with some fans for a kind of meet and
greet we were also able to do a kind of
Spinoza pilgrimage
since Spinoza is a person that we are
all definitely very interested in and
frankly is one of the most fascinating
philosophers of the Modern Age it was
great to walk in his footsteps to see
the places he grew up where he lived and
of course where he wrote his influential
Works Baruch Spinoza sometimes known as
Benedictus Espinoza was a 17th century
philosopher who was born and spent all
his life in the Netherlands
he came from a Sephardic Jewish
background his family having fled from
Spain or Portugal at some point and he
grew up in the Sephardic Jewish
community of Amsterdam the city had a
pretty sizable Jewish population with a
surprisingly large synagogue in which
the congregation would gather for
religious services
this synagogue known as the Portuguese
synagogue still survives and can be
visited today
the structure has changed very little
since the time of Spinoza even still
being without electricity basically
being only lit by candles in the
evenings it's really beautiful in other
words you can experience the place
pretty close to what it would have
looked like in Spinoza's own day and
when he would have attended this
synagogue it was also probably in here
that the leaders of the community would
have made the Fateful decision to have
Spinoza excommunicated
you see Espinoza grew up and started his
career as a philosopher as a young man
some of his ideas seem to have really
made the Jewish leaders uncomfortable
now we don't know exactly the reason for
his excommunication but Scholars will
argue that it probably had something to
do with his unique and daring ideas but
excommunicated he was nonetheless
something that must have been a very
tragic and certainly life-altering for
both him and his family
he left his hometown of Amsterdam and
would spend the rest of his life in
other parts of Holland where he would
continue to develop his very unique
philosophy he lived in a house in the
reinsburg close to Leiden for a while
before moving to the Hague in the last
years before his death in 1677 at the
meager age of 44. both of these houses
are places that you can visit today you
can see his library in the rinsburg
house which has been reconstructed with
his actual collection of books and even
an era appropriate Editions it's really
fascinating to see what kind of books he
had in his library and which thus of
course inspired his own thoughts and
ideas I spent some time in there with my
friends just studying his collection of
books and through that sort of getting
to know him in a more personal level
Spinoza is known for two philosophical
Works in particular firstly the
theological political Treatise published
anonymously during his lifetime in 1670
a work that has been infamously called a
book forged in Hell by its strong
critics
and secondly his Masterpiece the ethics
which was published after his death in
1677 and in these Works written in his
humble homes in rensburg and the Hague
he presents his daring ideas
Spinoza is famous partly for his
perspectives on God and metaphysics to
him reality consists of a single
substance and its different modes
he defines substance as quote that which
is in itself and is conceived through
itself and identifies this substance
with both God and nature
in other words God and nature are one
and the same thing to Spinoza at least
in some sense and that means that
everything is somehow a part of God or
as he says it all things are modes of
God or of substance
this is why he has been associated with
labels like pantheism or panantheism
simply the idea that everything is God
or that everything is a part of God
at the same time others have called them
everything from an atheist to a god
intoxicated man which are very diverse
conceptions of the man indeed this idea
in itself wasn't all that unique now
many philosophers and theologians in the
past had said similar things but Spinoza
was a strong rationalist inspired by
earlier thinkers like Descartes and he
greatly rejected things like Miracles
and any personal conception of God
he believed in God as the one substance
of reality identical in some way to
nature but not in God as a personal
being that could answer prayers or
perform miracles
this obviously has a significant impact
on his perspectives on scripture
religion and the state
as a staunch rationalist Spinoza cannot
accept many of the stories of the Bible
as true historical accounts to him the
Bible isn't really concerned with
knowledge as such in an intellectual
sense
scripture is primarily about an ethical
message he argues that the Bible was
composed for a broad audience for people
that are uneducated and unsophisticated
and as a result it takes the form of
Fantastical tales and miraculous stories
which when convey the true message in a
form that will speak to the common man
through things like well like I said
like stories or metaphors
for the philosopher however it's clear
that these stories must be read
metaphorically or allegorically getting
rid of all Superstition which he sees as
dangerous this True Religion the message
of which scripture carries is
essentially an ethical one
to love God and to love one's neighbor
is the core of our religion which one
should strive for not any of the
incoherent superstitious stuff that
Spinoza probably Rejects
heat rejects dogmatism and the way that
the church and religious institutions
claim sovereignty of the truth he
clearly separates between faith and
reason the domains of religion and
philosophy
religion is concerned with ethics and
morals philosophy is concerned with
truth and knowledge
scripture like the Bible doesn't contain
any metaphysical knowledge as such only
philosophy does
and this is what leads him to his very
strong political message one that is
still very much relevant today in
essence Spinoza very strongly emphasize
the freedom to philosophize freedom of
thought and expression as well as
freedom of religion
he even talks about democracy and
Praises it as the best political option
he said quote freedom is necessary first
and foremost for advancing science and
the arts for such Pursuits are only
cultivated with happy success by those
who have judgment that is free and
unhampered end quote
Spinoza is thus truly one of the most
important philosophers in history and
certainly of the Modern Age one that has
had a major impact on our world
his rationalism and emphasis on
tolerance and human freedom in society
makes him a kind of Forerunner to
liberalism as it is known today as well
as contemporary thought in general it's
really wonderful that so many places
associated with his life survive and can
be visited today
unlike when you study say medieval or
even ancient thinkers Spinoza lived
relatively recently and many of the
houses and places that he visited or
lived in they still stand today so you
can witness the places where he spent
his day working on books like the ethics
and experience the surroundings and
environment that served as his backdrop
at least relatively unchanged being in
his library in rensburg was especially
powerful to see and study the books that
would have been his intellectual
companions in the very place that he
actually lived and where he wrote his
daring ideas while the Jewish community
of Amsterdam still stand by their
excommunication the city and country are
today proud of Spinoza he stands
alongside figures like Descartes and
leibniz as foundational figures of
modern rationality and important figures
in the enlightenment his pantheistic
ideas where all of the world is a single
Unity that is God or substance or nature
can be inspirational today but also his
rationalistic readings of scripture and
heavy emphasis on freedom of thought and
favoring democracy as the best political
system
in the city of Amsterdam there is a
majestic statue of Spinoza close to the
old Jewish district and the synagogue
where he actually grew up and in a very
poetic way the statue is placed in such
a way that as the governor of the city
looks out of his window he sees the
bronze statue and perhaps most
importantly the words written on the
monument
the purpose of the state is freedom
encapsulating the message and importance
of Baruch Spinoza and his philosophy
I'll see you next time
[Music]